[Música]
llegaron a sap orilla a los 156 civiles
rescatados de la planta de soft al el
último bastión de la resistencia
ucraniana en mariupol rusia retomó el
asedio contra la acería donde permanecen
al menos 200 civiles más
el derecho de las mujeres a interrumpir
el embarazo en eeuu está bajo amenaza la
corte suprema confirmó que el borrador
filtrado de su opinión en el emblemático
caso roe versus wade es auténtico
decenas de ciudadanos protestaron en
varias partes del país
el secretario de relaciones exteriores
de mexico se reunió con el secretario de
seguridad nacional de eeuu
los funcionarios discutieron temas de
seguridad y migraciones puntualmente el
manejo regional del flujo migratorio y
oportunidades inmediatas de trabajo y
desarrollo para centroamérica ampliamos
desde ciudad de mexico
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
damos inicio en ucrania el presidente
volodymyr selenski informó que los 156
civiles que fueron evacuados de la
planta de as hostal considerada el
último bastión de la resistencia
ucraniana en mariupol llegaron a salvo a
la vecina ciudad de sap orilla una vez
finalizadas las evacuaciones de civiles
rusia retomó los bombardeos contra la
planta metalúrgica donde aún permanecen
otros 200 civiles el presidente vladimir
selenski resaltó que continuarán con
todos los esfuerzos para que todas las
personas que permanecen en la
instalación puedan salir de su mundo por
supuesto continuaremos haciendo todo
para sacar a toda nuestra población de
mariupol jacobs tal es difícil pero
necesitamos a todos los que están allá
civiles y soldados
no hubo ni un solo día que no
abordaremos esta situación así como
nuestro personal no haya tratado de
resolver esta situación
si logramos establecer un alto el fuego
durante casi tres días para que el
corredor humanitario funcionara corto o
sad o cross o te es la última población
al sur de nikolai va en control de las
fuerzas ucranianas es una posición
estratégica para detener el avance de
las tropas rusas hacia odessa el
principal puerto sobre el mar negro
su defensa depende de este frente que un
equipo de france 24 visito
esta carretera conduce mikolaj va al
puerto de gerson a 68 kilómetros al sur
que está en control de las fuerzas rusas
desde marzo y está en la entrada de
postal procaps que también alcanzó a
estar en manos enemigas
actualmente está bajo el control de los
ucranianos que los hicieron retroceder
son pocas las casas que han quedado
inmunes a los bombardeos
solo será cuestión de tiempo cuando
logremos hacerlos retroceder aún más y
logremos liberar gerson
esto es el frente
los rusos están a sólo 2 km y su
presencia se siente permanentemente
el colegio está en ruinas el ataque a la
edificación fue hace varias semanas pero
los bombardeos no cesan y la destrucción
aumenta con los días
la soledad de las calles contrasta con
el ladrido de los perros que han sido
dejados atrás por sus dueños
los hombres responsables de detener a
los rusos pertenecen a la brigada
mecanizada 28 del ejército ucraniano
el coronel cruz-coke y su comandante
adjunto
en el momento la situación está estable
el enemigo está tratando de atacar a
nuestras fuerzas pero gracias a nuestros
hombres los hicimos retroceder en 2
stojanovic antes de seguir su camino el
coronel hace un recuento del armamento
del enemigo
ven y tienen todo bmp tanques cohetes
antitanques muchas muchas armas
many many web es el comando central
ucraniano ha dicho que las fuerzas rusas
que están en gestión están tratando de
buscar las debilidades de las fuerzas
ucranianas y tomarse todo este sector
del país
vital es uno de los hombres responsables
de que el ejército ruso no avanza en
este frente lleva peleando contra ellos
desde hace ocho años en el donbass
entonces tenía 19 muchos de sus
compañeros han muerto
la pelea no fue tan dura para nosotros
ellos eran quienes atacaban pero
salieron corriendo fue una batalla a
nuestro favor
[Música]
saben que la defensa de este lugar es
estratégica y de ellos depende que ni
mykolaiv ni odesa caigan en manos
enemigas
en eeuu manifestantes salieron a
protestar frente a la corte suprema-
washington después de que se filtrara un
borrador de decisión que indicaba que
los jueces desestimarían el fallo que
garantiza el derecho constitucional a la
interrupción del embarazo el tribunal
confirmó la autenticidad del borrador y
ordenó una investigación sobre la
filtración que consideró un abuso de
confianza atroz
multitudes de activistas a favor y en
contra del aborto se congregaron frente
a la corte suprema de eeuu este martes
respondiendo un borrador de opinión
filtrado y anularía el histórico fallo
roe versus web
cuanto más analices la embriología más
te darás cuenta de que no son solo
algunas células son seres humanos
cuando me falló el control de la
natalidad mi esposo y yo tomamos la
decisión de tener un aborto legal y me
horroriza que esta decisión les sea
arrebatada a mis nietos y nietas
hablando fuera de la corte el líder de
la mayoría del senador chuck schumer
dijo que la decisión sería una
abominación y prometió una votación en
el senado para garantizar el acceso al
aborto a una votación sobre esta
legislación ya no es un ejercicio
abstracto esto es tan urgente y real
como parecía en el río
gates por su parte la corte suprema
emitió un comunicado confirmando la
autenticidad del documento pero dijo que
no representaba una posición final el
presidente del tribunal supremo john
roberts dijo que la publicación era una
traición pero que no detendrá las
discusiones mitch mcconnell el líder de
la minoría de la cámara alta- condenó la
filtración y acusó a los liberales de
querer intimidar a la corte coche la
corte debe desconectarse del ruido de la
mala fe y sentirse completamente libre
para hacer su trabajo
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden criticó el borrador
en primer lugar acabo de recibir una
llamada diciendo que se ha anunciado que
es un borrador real pero aún no
representa quien votará por él espero
que no haya suficientes votos
la idea que me preocupa mucho es que
después de 50 años vamos a decidir que
una mujer no tiene derecho a elegir
según los límites de la decisión de la
corte suprema-
y advirtió que otros derechos incluido
el matrimonio entre personas del mismo
sexo y el control de la natalidad sigue
adelante el secretario de relaciones
exteriores de méxico marcelo ebrard se
reunió en washington con el secretario
de seguridad nacional alejandro mayorkas
los funcionarios conversaron sobre el
manejo regional del flujo migratorio
justamente con el posible fin del título
42 que hace que los solicitantes de
asilo esperen en mexico por la solución
de su situación migratoria desde ciudad
de méxico mario carbonell y corresponsal
de france 24 nos dio previamente más
detalles
el canciller mexicano marcelo ebrard
viajó a washington para reunirse con
altos funcionarios de la administración
baiden en conferencia de prensa desde la
capital estadounidense
ebrard dijo que durante su encuentro con
alejandro mayorkas el jefe del
departamento de seguridad interior este
le hizo ver la preocupación de la casa
blanca por la creciente presión
migratoria que se incrementará aún más
cuando deje de estar en vigor el título
42 este mecanismo que permite a las
autoridades estadounidenses deportar de
manera inmediata a los solicitantes de
asilo argumentando razones sanitarias
por la pandemia de kobe 19 interrogado
respecto de que estaría méxico dispuesto
a hacer en este sentido ebrard dijo que
aplicarán sus propias leyes pues méxico
no permite el libre tránsito de
inmigrantes dijo que cualquier persona
indocumentada que desee transitar por el
país deberá registrarse para que el
estado pueda garantizar su seguridad
dijo que habló con mayor cas de instalar
una conferencia en centroamérica para
echar a andar un esquema conjunto de
creación de empleos pues dijo es la
única manera de reducir los flujos
migratorios dijo que también
un grupo de trabajo conjunto para
abordar esta situación asimismo se
reunió con antony blinken secretario de
estado con quien abordó detalles de la
próxima cumbre de las américas manifestó
la intención del gobierno mexicano de
que se invite a todos los países aunque
es sabido que washington no desea girar
invitaciones a los gobiernos de
venezuela nicaragua y cuba
y muy lentamente del consulado de eeuu
en la habana capital de cuba comenzó
nuevamente a emitir visas tras cuatro
años de cierre de la representación
diplomática
recordemos que la embajada
estadounidense fue cerrada por los
supuestos ataques sónicos contra su
personal diplomático que fue el punto de
inicio de un distanciamiento entre ambos
países la reapertura del consulado en la
habana de manera limitada y paulatina
fue anunciada el pasado 3 de marzo por
el encargado de negocios local sin haber
especificado una fecha precisa
es todo por el momento en france 24 a
ustedes les agradecemos su sintonía
continúen con nosotros que volvemos en
breve
[Música]